let's talk about why this is probably
the end of modern warfare we were hoping
we would have a little bit longer but
it's kind of not looking that way
i'm here joined by richie bracamonte to
talk over why this is good and bad for
different kinds of call of duty players
what cold war season 2 is doing and is
probably
going to do and we also want to hear
your thoughts we're going to go out and
look at the comments and see where you
guys are at
if you guys want to talk more about call
of duty please give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
alright let's get into it richie in our
previous video i kind of predicted that
modern warfare would keep
going and live on through warzone what
is cold war doing now that has kind of
dashed that hope
it's all starting with season two season
two is bringing a lot of
story elements from cold war and zombies
and stuff beginning with this big ship
that has
landed in for dansk which is full of
zombies we're getting all these uh
big computers everywhere that tell you
the infestation rate of zombies they're
all a bunch of little things but it's
kicking off a bigger story in terms of
cold war taking over
in 2019 and in 2020 we had a lot of
overflow from the modern warfare story
and it bled into warzone's baseline
story
so if you wanted to find the story
details out you were able to complete
the
challenges for the intel and the intel
led you to that cut scene where captain
price takes out zakayev
and stops the nuke and then calls in
soap it was a very big
cool scene for all his modern warfare
fans and we were all hoping for the
introduction of soap into the story and
into
multiplayer you know as a playable
character this isn't over
not by a long shot
so what's your position half a click off
the coast
things are really hitting up out here it
doesn't look like that's panning out
because
this whole cold war thing is taking over
i mean anything can happen but
they're really focusing and they're
really shifting the direction of the
story to
cold war and zombies and all of this
it's uh season two is kicking off
in a lot of big ways already so the
interesting thing is
we now also have some news about what we
think is gonna happen at the end of
season two
now to be fair something that we thought
was gonna happen you know at the end of
the modern warfare story arc which was
a map change getting the the map finally
newt and i think a lot of us were
were waiting for a long time for that to
happen i don't know if we expected the
map to get nuked and end with
with zombies which is a which is a very
treyarch thing to do but
it does seem like what you're talking
about it's that takeover of that
storyline but a map change so so we're
also talking about the map
coming in line with call of duty black
ops cold war it's probably gonna look
different
after the end of season two and that is
kind of the end of the modern warfare
era because
the genius of this map was that it had
all of the modern warfare maps on it
when modern warfare first launched
you would play the multiplayer maps and
you would recognize every one of these
locations
when you were playing warzone and they
they reinforced each other it was so
cool you knew all the
all the secret spots you could even fly
out of i believe it was superstore
and see the warzone map well before war
zone ever launched so that was such a
genius integration
and now with all the cold war maps being
there we're not sure quite yet if we're
gonna get the outbreak maps but that
seems to be like they're gonna all
erase that as well and now it's just
gonna mostly be potentially cold war
locations or
a significant number of cold war
locations might be added in
we're also adding some technical
limitations i mean if you want
cold war war zone and modern warfare
2019
it's a pain it's it's tough on people's
hard drives the official announcement
has come out that it's already becoming
such a struggle to keep
all of modern warfare 2019 on a
base playstation or a base xbox it's
getting harder and harder for people so
they're gonna have to pick and
of course if they you can play whatever
you want but
generally they'll probably shift towards
the newer game that's getting updates
and is getting support not to say that
everyone will
choose cold war over modern warfare 2019
and war zone because that's not true
but just logistically it's bound to
happen and the time is
approaching us now how crazy is that you
might have to
physically choose between the two games
if you have one of these base consoles
you physically can't fit it all on with
you know to be fair with all of their
texture packs and everything installed
but as you pointed out
they're gonna make these games larger
over time so even without those texture
packs i'm assuming you're still gonna
have to choose at some point between the
two games it's not just a story choice
it is a
physical choice unless you want to
expand your hard drive space alright so
that's kind of the conversation about
what's happening to
warzone the map and why modern warfare
is probably getting overwritten by cold
war
that's bad for modern warfare players
but there's a good side to this
richie you're a huge zombies fan and i
think a lot of people
feel that treyarch does zombies really
well so
how does outbreak and these sort of
zombie events
compare to what treyarch's done in the
past is this is this what
the cold war fans wanted for the most
part people
and and from what i've noticed people
are enjoying
the zombies experience that treyarch is
providing sometimes
i hear this more than the multiplayer
experience that they're providing
and i've sort of been in that ballpark
like i don't hate multiplayer but i've
been enjoying zombies a lot
and they're doing everything right as
far as i can tell so far personally
speaking i think
they're hitting the zombies train and
giving fans what they want
trying different things and integrating
it into the greater warzone experience
and you know we had fun with the zombies
event during halloween if we can get
some more limited time events like that
that'd be cool
but overall tree arc does zombies right
i mean they
they created it they're perfecting it
and i'm having a lot of fun with it
if they can keep hitting this and run
with it a lot of people are going to be
happy
but they can't ever neglect multiplayer
so it's a sticky situation for treyarch
to be in
they don't want to shoot themselves in
the foot but they make good zombie stuff
and
i'm personally enjoying it it's
interesting to go from outbreak
to the zombies event that is currently
building on the war zone map
i was having some trouble with it at
first and i was trying to figure out why
it kind of felt like blackout again
which was a step back from what it is
now
and i realized that treyarch made
blackout and so treyarch taking the
reigns on
warzone were having some of the same
issues the some of the same criticisms
that i had about blackout there was a
ship that showed up in blackout and
everybody dropped on the ship at the
same time
because they didn't spread the new stuff
around enough it was just kind of a
miserable experience trying to explore
the new things because
i mean of course everybody on the map is
going to drop the ship at the same time
so they're repeating some of their
mistakes like not spreading those events
out across the map granted there's a
couple of bunkers that you can go into
but again in the missile silos it says
the map's only five percent
infected we're assuming that's what that
means so this event should expand out
you know hopefully into whatever
culminates in the main event i think
treyarch still has some learning to do
in that department
yeah it's tough to kind of come back to
that but you're right you know
same with the stadium opening up like
the way when the stadium opened and we
got the trailer for black ops cold war
your mission was just to run to the
stadium and the trailer would play out
and uh you wouldn't really get to
explore the stadium but it was just a
fun way to like it was a fun community
thing and i think
right now everyone's tired of getting
hot dropped into the ship they just want
to explore and do their challenges
because there are challenges where you
can get
stuff or people who just want to play
plunder
they're getting it the worst they
they're getting dumped on man
they just want to play plunder because a
lot of people use plunder to just
respawn and navigate the boat as best as
they possibly can
it's a good idea but that plunder mode
is just like an excuse to do that
and if there are people playing plunder
seriously it's all bad for them right
now
just like the bunkers when they opened
up this will eventually cool off but
things are changing we might not have as
much time with this ship
as uh other events but the ship and the
whole zombies thing
is probably about to change the
landscape of war zones so
you know i just want some time with it i
want some peace with it so now we're
going to take some time out to read some
more user comments
we're enjoying these so please keep
sending them and liking them so they get
to the top so we can read them off for
you guys here in the videos
we'll start with cash money 99 who says
treyarch should just make zombies games
from now on and that's just something we
talked over right now
uh they're they know what they're doing
when it comes to zombies it'd be cool if
they had
you know all the funds just to put into
zombies that'd be cool that
since like the beginning players have
wanted a stand-alone zombies game and
it's always been tied to
black ops games so i agree i agree with
you cash money what do you think aaron
too many of you out there are also
saying that you're basically just using
cold war to level your guns for war zone
if that's all you're using it for
then you're mostly just enjoying war
zone or you're just enjoying zombies
treyarch i think you're great at zombies
keep doing zombies
and maybe just focus on zombies again
i'm a modern warfare player full
disclosure
uh there are people who love cold war
and they love that old-fashioned
call of duty arcade style so i've said
this in previous videos you guys are
awesome
this is just coming from a modern
warfare fan so over on twitter we talked
about the
possible nuke event that's going to
happen and that it's all but confirmed
and we got some comments one from
gameguru who says finally
i can't play this map anymore it's been
a damn year
aaron what do you know it you know it
has been a year
and that's incredible because you know
fortnite which really kicked off a lot
of this stuff
um and apex have been changing their
maps and adding new maps and doing
pretty significant stuff
the rumor was that the nuke event was
supposed to happen and got delayed
into cold war which kind of makes sense
given all the cutscenes and everything
that happened come on you can only play
the same map for so long even if it's a
good map
and it is definitely time to change this
is the upside of cold war taking over
it's just i just can't keep playing the
same map
again and again just that's a big ask
for people it is i'm with you as much as
i love verdansk it'd be
uh and uh rebirth was okay just more
variety the better i know that's not
easy
or good for your hard drive but you know
the way apex did it was
was fine they took away the first map
for a while brought it back later
and kind of rotated the maps for for
battle royale and
i think it worked out there it's time
for a change you said there were some
data mines involving
maybe this is totally unconfirmed but
maybe lava and some crazy things so
we'll see how far they take it but we're
again like modern warfare is dead
we're heading into like fantasy
direction as far as we can tell now
so from our call of duty should be
afraid of battlefield video we got some
user comments
uh one of them from please die says
he's quoting me says sledgehammer has a
good track record so far
worst quote i've heard in a little bit
okay
yeah i'm gonna switch my hat
[Laughter]
yeah and i get this like for sure and
i'm
this is coming from i would say more of
a semi-classic
call of duty player you know roughly i
started playing
cod 4 a little bit of cod 3 but mostly i
got into credit card 4.
i stopped at ghosts you know because as
soon as i heard of like advanced warfare
and
jumping and all this goofy stuff i was
like out
right like a lot of people my age like i
knew what i liked to my call of duty and
i wasn't going to pay for one that
didn't didn't satisfy these likes i was
this whole future thing was so goofy
but you know for the sake of this job i
had to go back and play some of these
games and
and to be able to talk about them and
make videos about them
and i played advanced warfare and i
enjoyed the story for sure so i will
defend it
and i played online and i liked it as
well i liked it better than i thought so
i'm kind of eating my words when it
comes to how i feel about that game but
i know i know where you're coming from
but i will defend advanced warfare
and world war ii all right i'm going to
take some heat on the next one
from our early outbreak gameplay that we
put up when you could
play outbreak ahead of time by taking it
offline userson101 said i don't think
this guy's ever played zombies before
i know please stop watching it
no no like the funny thing was is that
like we have two modes we usually have
journalism mode where we try and get
something
up really quick because something's
happening and we just want to show you
guys
and our preference which is like get as
good of gameplay as we possibly can
but it was funny because the minute i
put that one up you know a couple rounds
later i was like oh man i i sh
i should put this up because this is way
better and then i watched the numbers
just keep climbing and climbing and i
was like yeah
everybody stop watching this one so yeah
like
come on we we know when something is not
as good as we want it to be
um and we really do appreciate you guys
watching it and we're glad that we could
show you guys that
outbreak leaked a little bit early in
offline mode um
and hopefully we gave people a couple
hours or
you know a jump on the day to play it
before it actually launched
so we do appreciate it and we know all
right so that is why we think that
modern warfare is at an end
i know a lot of us have been holding out
hope for a long time and it's sad to see
it go
but cold war players out there are
getting a lot of what they want
and also zombie fans out there are
getting some fantastic modes
and potentially like a huge nuke event
hopefully involving zombies on the
warzone map alright if you also like
your call of duty nostalgia richie just
finished his evolution of the mp5 it's a
fantastic video and you should go check
it out or head on over to gamespot or
gamespot's youtube page for coverage of
more shooters and other games
alright thanks for watching
[Music]
you